you've all heard the expression a child
shall lead them well you're about to
meet the youngest presenter ever to
appear on the Oscars
he's the sensational new star of the
champ with him as a former Oscar winner
and still a champion here are mr. Ricky
Schroder and Miss Shirley Jones
Ricki I don't think I could have a
better escort tonight than you thank you
what do you think of the nominated
pictures this year I don't know I won't
be allowed to see most enough charm 17
well you have a lot to look forward to
would you like to help me read the
nominees for outstanding achievement in
art direction I'll give my best shot
nominees for outstanding achievement art
direction are the bring strong art
direction by Dean tava loris and Angelo
Graham set decoration by George our
Nelson and Bruce cake California sweet
art direction by Albert Brenner set
decoration by Marvin March heaven can
wait art direction by Paul Silbert and
Edwin O'Donovan set decoration by George
gains deuterium's art direction by male
born set decoration by Daniel Robert art
direction by Tony Walton and Philip
Rosenberg set decoration by Edward
Stuart and Robert Drumheller and the
winners are Paul Silbert and Edwin
O'Donovan for heaven way
I would like to thank all the people who
contributed their time and their talent
to the sets for heaven can wait and I'd
like to thank God and mrs. Roth two
locations I want to thank my good friend
all silver who brought this about my
thanks to Warren Beatty Mike Hinkle liar
Gary Kudrow and Academy thank you